[Music]
c-span the cable satellite public
affairs network and its companion
network c-span 2 are funded entirely by
america's cable television companies as
a public service
here's a look at what's ahead on the
schedule this evening all times listed
here are eastern times only
next on c-span it's book notes our guest
this week is author christopher hitchens
here to discuss his book titled for the
sake of argument
then at 9 10 p.m on this week's look at
politics in the united kingdom it's a
conversation with margaret douglas who
is the superintendent of parliamentary
broadcasting
and then at about 9 40 p.m we will once
again bring you a special look at the
oval office including the tour with
president bill clinton
that's the c-span schedule at this hour
[Music]
this is book notes c-span 60-minute
discussion with the authors of public
policy historical and political works
for the next hour you'll see behind the
titles and gain insight into the authors
as people and the experiences which
shape their lives
this week our guest is christopher
hitchens
columnist for vanity fair and the nation
he joins us to discuss his recent book
for the sake of argument
christopher hitchens author of all the
little articles in the new book called
for the sake of us of argument you've
got a section in there called rogue's
gallery was that your idea yes
where who are they why why why create a
rogues gallery for a lot of people their
first love is what they'll always
remember for me it's always been the
first hate
and i think that hatred though it
provides often rather junky energy is a
terrific way of getting you out of bed
in the morning keeping you going it can
be if you don't let it get out of hand
it can be catalyzed into writing
and um in this country where people like
to be non-judgmental when they can be
which translates us on the whole lenient
there are an awful lot of bubble
reputations floating around that
you know one wouldn't be doing one's job
if one didn't itch to prick
so you mentioned one right away because
a couple of months ago back during the
bush administration in some article i
remember popping up a paragraph that
said dan quayle's favorite book that
he's reading is i think it was called
the modern society by paul johnson
modern times
times by paul johnson you
you have paul johnson in your rogues
gallery who is he let me just say about
that very point modern times and paul
johnson's terrible reaction to british
historian
pseudo-historian i'd say
he used to be the christmas gift of rich
nixon
um he in the quail and bush era became a
cult figure on the right and there's a
wonderful description in peggy noonan's
book of walking past quail's office and
seeing modern times portentously
open a certain page quail is reading
this book and walking busted several
weeks later and seeing that we're still
open at the same page um
he's a cult on the american right um
he used to be my editor um at a british
leftist liberal magazine called the new
statesman once a very famous
weekly review where we both worked and
he's probably the classic instance of
the guy
who um having lost his faith believes
that he's found his reason
in other words a defector
and he's become
a very
faroush
thatcherite
figure and he wrote a terrible book
called intellectuals which i decided i
would unload upon
and at some point in this piece
that you have and this is a book of all
kinds of pieces you've written for a lot
of different publications
you know where it is you say sorry about
that paul i think uh
was it is it hard to
punch at somebody you know or used to
work it can be harder yes and george
orwell used to say i won't have lunch
with x or y because i'm going to write
about him soon and i'm sure i'm going to
find he's really quite nice and
therefore i don't want the corrupting
effect of
a sort of acquaintanceship or friendship
i'd rather keep
clean and keep pure i have stone in
washington used to do the same thing he
wouldn't go to briefings and
little soirees because he he wanted to
be able to say what he thought about
people i actually i'm not that fortunate
i'm compulsively social but with with um
johnson
i had to say look um in your book
intellectuals you have said that certain
people mainly
liberal and radical intellectuals can be
defamed grossly defamed actually in his
book on grounds their private life
wasn't exemplary well paul
used the first name i know you and i
think it's unwise of you
to make the private life
the measure of anything
yeah like for instance you say that um
this often involved drunken and boris
conduct towards women including his wife
this is up for frontline
yeah i know i had to say
i had to say look i don't think this
kind of stuff counts
i if i was writing about voltaire would
not go and look in his linen basket
in order to to attack his ideas but if
you're going to do it
then you become a hostage to it yourself
and so the first part of the piece is
supposed really to be a lampoon i say if
i was doing johnson
as a political figure and if i was
johnson doing it i'd do it like this
just to show him how it feels
then i i hope successfully and i make a
transition in the rest of the article
and say actually
that's all for sure that's not the point
the problem with johnson's theory about
about gnome chomsky who attacks
revoltingly about voltaire
about marx
about other great figures of the the
modern world
um
canon should be attacked in other ways
and
i don't know what the american
equivalent of this of this is exactly um
but in england there's a motto so
schoolboy type morality motto which says
that you
you tackle the ball and not the man
this book has a picture black and white
picture on the cover of you
sitting there with a cigarette in your
hand
and is it i can't see where i am is that
alcohol there in front of you there are
about nine or ten empty glasses in front
of me
only two or three of them are mine i
hope it's clear
and i think only probably about two of
them are filled or have just been
emptied
of booze it's me slumped over a dinner
table the night i got married as a
matter of fact and annie leibovitz was
there and took a picture of me
which i thought did actually look for
better or worse pretty much like i do
let's take a look at it again um
this your idea to put this on the cover
well partly it was because not everyone
has the chance to have their picture
taken maddie leibovitz and second
because she's a genius photographer and
she does capture what i'm like
after about eight o'clock in the evening
and third is one of the longer articles
in the book is the defense of smoking
and drinking
and of alcohol and nicotine against the
current sort of prohibitionist mentality
that's sweeping
the country it's a it's a sort of
in-your-face reply to the new
puritanism that expression on your face
i'm sitting here now for example
thinking
how much i like these sorts of
discussion and thinking but if i just
have brandy and soda there and an
ashtray
how much better a side of me you'd be
seeing you think that's you
yeah i'm afraid sir i have to face it
like everyone else
i keep mentioning all well but he says
that the i think he says at the age of
40 a man has the face he deserves i
won't see 40 again so i guess i'm stuck
with that now
the purpose of a book like this
well um
i wrote it as a as a reply i mean the
pieces are very various
that's what i think anyway
they're a salad
uh but they have a common theme which is
it's a reply to all those who say
that um since the 1989 revolution
that there's really no need for the left
critique of society or politics anymore
that we've moved beyond all that society
is just is just basically a liberal
problem-solving
matter and no more um though the
conservatives i noticed are still
allowed to have their say implicitly
everything in there is about
the origins of the 1989 revolution in
eastern europe which are covered in some
part
and its consequences
um and i define it as a real
emancipating revolution
that i'd long hoped for and worked for
and supported but one that by no means
makes politics any more one-dimensional
i mean i think actually it restores the
left as a very necessary part of the
political argument so even when i'm
writing about something else i'm always
trying to bear that in mind and the
articles come from
places like a magazine called the nation
sure if someone's never read the nation
what is it the nation is america's
oldest political weekly magazine was
founded in 1865 uh towards the end of
civil war by a group of abolitionists
and it's it's basically upheld the
liberal left
end of the spectrum held up that end of
the rope um ever since
um and still proudly comes out every
week and every other week it features
and has for the last 10 years a column
by me called minority report
which sometimes about politics sometimes
about a new book sometimes about a
personality but
is again an attempt to mount a left
critique of society in politics there
are other
publications like times literary
supplement what times the london times
uh the tls as it's called translatory
software it sells independently as a
weekly and actually
half its subscribers are in the united
states um and i used to be its american
columnist
and in there i've written about more
general subjects like the work of graham
greene
or pg woodhouse is perhaps my favorite
author
um and a couple of other more more
literary pieces but again in there i try
put it like this i try when i'm writing
about literature not to leave the
political dimension out and when i'm
writing about politics i try and and
recall that politics isn't all there is
to life and try and import
what you might call
cultural literary or aesthetic points to
it isn't this must make me sound
insufferable but i mean i'm i'm
that's my ambition anyway isn't pg
woodhouse's uh another
person that writes about him all the
time george will
yes
you get into terrifically bad company
some of the time if you're a fan of
woodhouse
uh that's actually true that's true of
also being a fan of kipling or orwell or
many other people pg woodhouse is the
author of the most imperishable i think
um double act in in fictional
history that's uh bertie worcester and
his manservant jeeves
and
it's impossible i mean of course a joke
is never a joke if it has to be
explained but to those who haven't
found and discovered and immersed
themselves in this i can only say they
should start today
and
when you're referring it sounds a bit
cultish but those who've already done it
will already know what i'm talking about
who is he
was
he died at the age of um about 93 in the
mid 70s he was um
an english comic writer who as a matter
of fact got driven out of england rather
partly by poverty and moved to america
which he adored
and stayed for the last 50 or so years
his life on long island but he was
always writing about the sort of
mythical golden past of the english
country house and of the english
gentleman of leisure and man about town
in london bertie worcester who's a
complete chinless idiot and can't get
himself out of any scrape
of any any sort without the help of his
amazingly impassive
brilliant classically educated
as he's called in the stories personal
gentleman's gentleman the butler
achieves
um who's always rescuing him it's it's
not unlike um
the importance of being earnest uh these
are guys who would be nowhere without
their servants
and always getting involved in
ridiculous love affairs that have to be
explained to them and they have to be
hauled out of and stood up on their feet
again another member of your rose
gallery is henry kissinger
of who's rogue's gallery is he not a
yeah member mark mark twain said uh if
you give a man a reputation as an early
riser um he can sleep till noon
kissinger somewhere or another along the
line picked up a reputation as a
statesman and peacemaker
um a negotiator and sort of miraculous
deal and and uh dealmaker and bridge
builder
i invite people in this piece to
consider
any instance in which he's left a
country or a cause or problem
better off than when he found it
and i also point to what i consider to
be a record of crime
um his past i mean he's he's been
complicit in
the commissioning of assassinations and
and in the covering up of mass murder
and i think actually there are some
signs in his own memoirs and his
behavior that he enjoys it
um that he's a very dangerous person a
war criminal and you say you're social
and i give the i give the list of um
instances where i believe that to be
true and i'll give them here and now if
you like
before you do that you say you're a
social person uh he is known to be
social from time to time have you ever
come across well as a matter of fact i
have twice been um on the verge of being
introduced to him and and broken my
usual rule which is
i think for a journalist a necessary one
you know there's no hand one shouldn't
shake one's job is to see everyone and
talk to everyone and do everything but i
can't do it with him i've just had to
turn away and once was rude before doing
searching
in other words i feel that everyone must
have some kind of moral last ditch and
this is mine i couldn't
i couldn't be polite to him
and so
it would be hypocritical um to be as it
were presented not that he cares or even
notices i'm sure you don't think he
notices well it's difficult to say he's
often shown he's got a very thin skin i
mean when the psy hush book came out he
went into terrific tantrum if you
remember and he also went into a great
tantrum about walter isaacson's book
of which this is a review um he's not at
all he likes to think he's intolerant
generous broad-minded and when he's on
nightline with no opposition
he likes to crack the odd rather
sinister joke but i don't think in fact
he does have any talent for
introspection or humor or um self-doubt
or self-criticism whatever we can come
back to more on henry christian possibly
there's so much to talk about i want to
move on to mother teresa
yes you have a piece in here
that uh was in the nation in april of
1992 and you call this the ghoul of
calcutta
mother teresa mother teresa
i i always had a real doubt in my mind
as to whether there really was this
saintly person and if you ask people why
do they think mother teresa is so great
they'll always say well isn't it true
that she spends her time always you know
helping out the poor of carl carter
but if they really push them they don't
know anything about her at all they just
take it on faith as saints always are
taken
so i went to calcutta actually for
another reason i thought well i'm there
i'll go and look her up and i was rather
appalled by what i found i mean she was
she showed me around her mission and she
announced that the purpose of the
mission
was to run a campaign in calcutta in
bengal
against abortion and contraception
now as it happens i'm i'm i have my
doubts about abortion
uh i find i'm very squeamish on the
subject but
one thing that calcutta definitely does
not need
is a campaign waged by an albanian
catholic missionary against the
limitation of the population
and it it rather to me spoiled the
effect of her charitable work that she
was saying actually this is not charity
it's religious propaganda
um and i think the vatican policy on
population control is calamitous
um
so that aroused my curiosity anyway it
had been a bit of a disappointment
meeting her there and i didn't like her
manners actually particularly either as
she went
around around a monk excuse me
the poor then i found her turning up as
the defender of the duvalier family in
haiti
um saying how lovely they were and how
gentle and beautiful then i found her
turning up as
charles keating's personal best friend
in the lincoln savings and loan scandal
taking a lot of money from him for a
private plane giving him blessings and
crucifixes in return then i found it
turning up in albania where she's a
supporter of a very extreme right
nationalist party
and quite a few other such things and i
thought hey i don't like any of these
things
singly or together and second when does
she ever get time for the poor of
calcutta
she's forever on some
scumbags learjet going around cashing in
on the everyone else's belief that she's
the same and i think this is probably
how medieval religion was worked
but let's say as a con people just you
know you you took the faithful as
credulous and you reckon that they would
believe whatever you said let me just
take her aside for purpose of discussion
let's say that she went to the de
valliere family and got money went to
charles keating and got money and moved
it over to the poor wouldn't that be
charity i i don't think it's necessary
for someone who's who is supposedly
consecrated to the mission of charity
and who's world famous for it
to ever have to beg for money if she
ever wanted it she knows where to go for
it people would open their pockets so
that i think their hearts no the fact is
um i don't even know she got any money
from the values what she was doing was
defending them as a dynasty in haiti and
everyone knows what the record of the
valley family is
she did get money from keating and i
actually asked in my piece you know
would she care would anyone care to say
that they know where it's gone
because she must have known or should
have known that that money doesn't
belong to keating and doesn't belong to
her sterling money
but okay
let her say but the fact is
she was giving him in return various
kinds of absolution
in his campaigns and i think this is
because you know he started off life as
a moral cop he was another of the
prohibitionists he's a began his career
as an anti-anti-pornography person
she's she's evidently it seems to me on
on call for people dubious characters of
this kind i just thought it was worth
pointing out i can't tell you the mail i
got about it i mean if you if you touch
the idea of saying to it especially in
this country people feel you've taken
something from them personally
um and i'm fascinated because of course
we like to look down on other religious
beliefs as being tribal and
superstitious
never dare criticize our own over the
years what has brought you the most mail
that was one um
gosh my mind suddenly goes blank when i
think while the other mailbags well
actually a piece i once wrote about um
about henry kissinger was another one um
that was in the london review
disagreement people writing the
well i shouldn't be the one to say but
actually people were writing and saying
i've long wanted someone to write about
him in that way not to write about him
as if he was a great statesman but as if
he was a great criminal there's another
piece here was in the condi nast
traveler in 1990
and it's about pj o'rourke and it says
not funny enough
what are you doing writing for the conde
nast traveler listen i'm i'm not in a
position to turn anyone down i'm very
proud if anyone ever asks me um
i in fact i work part of the time for
continuous more or less all the time
actually i write a column of vanity fair
called
called cultural elite which appears
every month now by the way what's who's
kanye nest oh connie nest is the well
colleen was a an individual a great
publisher and designer
and he started the family of magazines
that we associate with
vogue
fantasy fair which is its flagship a
travel magazine called conde nast
traveler um
the new yorker
um in other words you know the core of
american magazine life now owned by the
new house family
pj o'rourke is in uh in your rose
gallery pj rock is a guy who gets away
in my opinion with murder i mean he's um
he's another ex-leftist
um 60s radical dropout wrote very
funnily about what it was like being
permanently stoned and bummed out and
paranoid in the 60s then saw the light
put on a collar and tie became a young
republican and has been cashing in this
chip ever since
and has terrific sort of following as a
humorist
um for his books of essays one the first
one quite funny is called republican
party reptile
and the next one was called is called
holidays in hell and more recent one is
called give war a chance
and these sell totally well among the
young much better than any of my books
ever have
and it gets me down so this is my
revenge upon him do you know what yeah i
met him sure and he has quite a good guy
to hang out with in a bar and so forth
but i i've reckoned that he was running
on empty with this joke about i know
i know i've been there i've been in the
radical now i see how wonderful it would
be to be
a completely buttoned-up button-down
tory
and the joke basically depends on
on a satire on political correctness
okay so people try not to make jokes
about aids pj will make a joke about
aids
okay it's not funny to laugh at cripples
will i laugh but cripples and i said
look
in the words of the title of the review
that's not that's quite funny but it's
not funny enough
it's a gentle rebuke
where were you born portsmouth was with
hampshire england no i'm a navy brat in
other words well what did your dad do
it's a lifetime
um naval officer in
the service of the king and and indeed
of the empire and until i was i don't
know about 12 i wanted to do the same
are your dads alive no less
your mother
how many kids in the family
just me and my brother my brothers are
very conservative
journalist um writes for
a
conservative tabloid in england called
the daily express he's just in fact
become his washington
correspondent
um he's having been in moscow for it for
a long time he's very brilliant guy
very
very thoughtful very good writer
with political views polar opposite of
mine he's just just arrived in
washington this week so i'm looking
forward to i'm thinking i'll probably
have to give a party or something and
say
okay
here's the hitchens family secret now
you know everything what's his first
name pizza
and is it daily express the paper that
uh that lord bieber wrote that's right
it was people books flagship i used to
work for it myself but i i had i had to
quit it was too much for me you grew up
in portsmouth which in great britain is
located where in the country it's on the
south coast and it's if you could think
of the south coast as a
sort of line at an angle to europe and
there's a small island called the isle
of wight
which forms a perfect by protecting a
certain area of the coast it forms a
perfect natural harbor in portsmouth is
where lord nelson
last set foot on land before before
joining her ship and going off to
trafalgar for example it's always been
the home port of the of the british navy
it's where the great ships were built um
it still is very much in that maritime
tradition and there's a graveyard full
of hitches on ports downhill that
overlooks it what year were you born
1949. how long did you live there in
portsmouth not roughly long at first
because my father was being moved around
a lot the there was still quite a big
british naval and military presence in
the world then
and the first place i can remember is
the island of malta in the mediterranean
which is then a semi-colony of the
united kingdom that's where my brother
was born and so my first memory is of
the grand harbor at valletta which is by
the way a magnificent
thing to have as your first memory it's
why i've always loved
i think the mediterranean
and then we were sent to a navy base in
scotland we moved around like that we
came back to portsmouth for a bit the
place i spent longest in is oxford and
then london
and your father politically was what
very conservative your mother
um
uh brother moore of the compassionate
liberal type my mother
how'd that work
well actually i must say for them i mean
neither of them attempted to impose
their political opinions on me
and until i developed my own views i
didn't really know what theirs were i
mean then i found out that my father
actually was he really believed it all
about
basically the conservative party the
monarchy
not so much the church of england i
don't think but the
you could say what it stood for and and
felt sad and bad about the decline of
england as a country and and as and as a
society sorry hard to say and as a
society
you went to so pessimistic and
pessimistic and a bit resentful of the
way things had turned out in its old age
yes i went to oxford university how did
you get in
well i was the first member of my family
to go to university um or certainly to
go to
oxford and um
and i worked we had as a family to sort
of work out the steps if you want to be
upwardly mobile in britain that's the
key thing
so the step one is you have to go to a
private school basically if you're
starting from where we were so my
parents made a big sacrifice to send me
to private school
where in cambridge actually a methodist
public school in cambridge called elise
good pretty good school and there i
decided that i knew exactly what i
wanted to do i wanted to become a writer
um were you making good grades
throughout all this period good enough
yeah and then you have to have certain
grades to try for oxford and then you
sit a separate exam and have an
interview and so on and i knew that i
wanted to go to belial college in oxford
and i wanted to read philosophy politics
and economics the ppe courses it's
called and i wanted and i wanted to be a
writer or conceivably a politician so i
knew from very early on what i wanted to
do who went to balial that you knew or
that you inhibited now why that i knew
about in history well most of the last
five or six prime ministers had been
there and a lot of the
radical journalists and historians and
and authors had been there was a kind of
forcing house
for i mean it's resented in the fact
that even the opposition types come you
know the famous ones come from have been
to the same colleges as the ruling class
but in a small country in a very
encrusted society like that probably
unavoidable who's your favorite radical
journalist in history in history
i suppose i'd have to say george orwell
i i know it's cliched because everyone
now pretends to admire him but there was
a long time when he wasn't well known
and certainly not well liked
and i think it shows in his prose and
it's those bits of his prayers that i
admire he got to be honest no he didn't
go to university at all nor did my
living favorite uh gor vidal go to
college either i've always thought
that's a good council to people who
think that credentials are everything
you don't have to do any of that orwell
went to a privileged public school but
he then went off to be
again because the poverty of his family
went off to be a colonial policeman in
burma what did you like about george
orwell
well um again not sound too conventional
about it um i think he really would
follow
logic and honesty to their
to their full conclusion i mean he would
not be deflected by the fact that this
might offend someone
he knew
or some cause which was associated or
more important i mean wouldn't
even discompose himself in other words
he thought okay if i don't like this
conclusion i'm still sticking with it if
it's
if it's been arrived at honorably it
sounds like an easy thing to do or to
say but it's actually very hard to live
by and i think he really did live by it
i thought he i thought he put up a good
show for the left
in his life at a time when it was in
great difficulty because
people were pressed very hard to say
look if you're on the left you must
support the soviet union because it's
endangered and it's encircled by fascism
so on and you mustn't criticize it in
public even if you have your doubts he
said no that that would be stupid
that would be giving up
the thing that makes me a radical in the
first place which is the right to think
for myself that was a lot harder to do
now than it sounds again
and then i think he was a very witty and
brilliant
stylist i think his
writings on other authors like dickens
for example
his reflections on
eternal subjects like capital punishment
for example or family life ordinary
things every arguments that never go
away always worth rereading when did you
come to the united states 1980
why
well i've been coming ever since i left
university i came here on a scholarship
in 1970
to work to it was a traveling
scholarship you got to travel all around
the u.s
and i decided then and there that i'd
rather live in america i thought it was
great
and um
i nearly didn't go back when the
scholarship right now but i sort of had
to because i was out of dough and
actually there was
well there was a there was a woman in
the case i actually had to go back to
england
so it didn't come back again for about
another five or six years but started
coming more and more often and then the
nation offered me a job
so i i took about 10 seconds to decide
yeah i'm coming for good where have you
lived in the united states new york at
first and then in washington i've been
in washington for nearly 10 years now i
can hear folks saying he likes it here
in the united states and he's a
socialist yeah sure
i'm sure you've heard that before
if you want to socialism why did you
come to the united states well i
i think it's a good question um and ask
it myself i mean there's a long
tradition
that's unfortunately been buried
forgotten um
and it's exemplified by i suppose
the greatest englishman and the greatest
american certainly the greatest
anglo-american thomas paine
who is in effect i mean the moral author
of the declaration of independence and
of important bits of the constitution
and who
wrote the crisis and wrote common sense
and was one of the people who really
nerved the
colonial leadership to actually separate
and declare for the united states was
the first person ever to use the term
the united states of america
um would have written slavery out of the
constitution if he'd been allowed he
wasn't allowed to would have put the
emancipation of women in
again lost that battle i think how much
trouble would have been saved if he'd
won
and is
the founding radical really of the
british left
and they don't know it of american
democracy too
so i
wouldn't dream of
comparing myself
to him obviously but i mean to say he's
the founder of a tradition that does
exist in both countries of which i'm
proud to be a supporter at any rate and
which i try
in stuff i've written in my previous
book i wrote a long defense of thomas
paine try to uphold and live by
um
i think america has a fantastic radical
tradition
very admirable one
um it goes from thomas paine through
well
through the anti-slavery campaigners
particularly john brown and um william
lloyd garrison some of whom
their descendants were associated with
the nation incidentally through eugene
debs
through martin luther king through cesar
chavez
and that's my that's my tradition if i
if i can make such a bold claim i hope
not to disgrace it anyway even if i
don't
enhance it
uh
there was a show that we did a number of
i can't remember exactly when it was
when you had a young man standing by you
when we opened the show up alexander
your son
uh is this you're married
i'm not married to his mother anymore
but i'm married again yes and
how many children do you have well i
have two and i have one on the way by my
new wife
so i'm about to become
an exemplar of family values one way or
another
uh let's go back to
oxford because in the book you have a
number of articles about
then candidate bill clinton yes you went
to oxford at the same time
did you know him there no i didn't i
knew
the house where he lived 46 lecture road
quite well because it was a well-known
hangout for
um american
exile usually rhodes scholar but not
always
anti-war and pro-civil rights people and
those were my friends and i knew people
who knew bill clinton and i still do
know some of them
and i remember the milieu very well and
i remember we used to do all kinds of
stuff to help out the american anti-war
students so i think we're being very
brave at the time much braver than
they're given credit for but i i'm sure
i've looked at pictures of him at the
time i'm sure i don't remember him who
did you during the campaign i used to
say to people i can prove to you bill
clinton is a moderate
as he claims because if he was an
extremist i definitely would have known
him what were you like there
what was i like yeah well i was as i
still am an extreme leftist did you
speak out yeah
i mean there's an occasion where we we
may even have been on the same platform
but there's no picture of it that i can
find which was the the um the moratorium
against the war which is remember huge
candlelit meetings in all the american
cities
against the war stop it now shut it down
the moratorium and in every european
city there was a sympathy demonstration
there was quite a big one in oxford
where i spoke
and i know that clinton was there and he
may even have spoken with me but
i can't i can't get him i can't bring
his picture back into my mind who did
you know then that we would know now
there's a guy called ira magazine
who is
sort of in charge of what's laughingly
called hillary clinton's healthcare task
force and who is
was always the sort of technical and
organizing brain of the americans in
oxford and he's considered to be a very
terrific number cruncher and
and uh
reasoner of that sort i remember him
very well and he was at my college
um george stephanopoulos was there later
bail had a special attraction often to
these
kinds of americans my own colleagues did
but but bill no and i as i say i think
that proves that he must have been
um as he says he was one of the more
moderate anti-war people can you
remember when you became a socialist
pretty much yeah what year well i know
when i decided that i supported the
victory of the labour party which as you
know is a very different thing but that
was in 1964. and i had been reading i've
been reading a lot of all well i've been
reading the actual thing that had more
influence on me almost than anything was
the perch of wilfred owen
who is he he was the great purge of the
first world war
um he wrote a wonderful poem called
anthem for doomed youth and another
just a latin title dolce de cora best
you know that's on all war memorials
sweet and seemly to die for the country
fantastically powerful anti-war poetry
written from the trenches
and very tragically he was killed um
i think on the very last day of the
first world war or the day before
the very last
moments of the nightmare his mother got
the telegram about his death as the
bells the church bells were turning for
victory in 1918.
and it had a
tremendous effect on me reading that
another book which some people may
remember called how green was my valley
by the welsh mining valleys introduced
me to the idea which had been strange to
me up until then if there being such a
thing actually as a working class
um with a word life and mind of its own
and you can't be a socialist if you
don't think that when did you start
writing and enjoying it or do you enjoy
writing
i don't really know if i do or not i
mean i i hate not writing i know that
and i sort of do it because i feel i
have to
sometimes it's real pleasure doing it
usually the pleasure comes though when
when you see it in print not until then
where are you and usually not till
sometime after where do you write well i
write a column every month of an answer
fair called cultural elites
oh i'm sorry um
i write on the table at home in longhand
but when we see this picture though do
we is this the what what you look like
when you're writing this cigarette in
the hand and uh yeah i sometimes rise in
bars too in the afternoons
in bars yeah i go out and find the
corner of a bar quite like if the noise
isn't directed at me in other words it's
not a phone ringing or baby crying or
something i quite like it if the jukebox
is on and people are shouting the odds
about a sports game i just
hunched over a bottle in the corner and
i write in longhand anyway so i can do
it anywhere sometimes in airport
terminals
and then when i've got enough down
i start to type it out
editing it as i go i don't use any of
the new technology stuff
do you have a technique that gets
people's attention i mean is there
something oh i should ask you
well there's a headline here's one let's
try this one on i didn't know where this
one was published i'll find out i
trusted to full open
newsday july 1990 when how often did you
write for newsday i used to do a book
column for them every week this is
called a pundit who need never dine
alone that's george will george will yes
and you start off here by saying study
and ponder the following lines written
by george f will as ronald reagan went
tottering back to his california estate
in 1989.
and then you go on to lam bastian for
writing what you said is basically
intelligible well i thought i think it's
i think george will stuff is very
affected and overwritten yes it's full
of
i think rather bogus shows of learning
and classical tags and things of this
kind i have a weakness sometimes for
quotations of that sort myself so i
think i recognize the disease in others
and it's in a very advanced stage in his
case i think he's a courtier i think
especially during the reagan era he
basically was making a living
as a as a professional flatterer of the
reagan nancy the ron and nancy court
and i think that's right i don't think
journalists should do that
i think it's
even more important not to do it when
your friends are in power
speaking of
what's wrong with it yeah well i think
one thing it'll congest your style very
badly you'll be full of things you can't
really say things that are half
confidences that have been given to you
by people in power your stuff will start
to puff up your your paragraphs will
start to get rotund with
all the things you could say if you
really wanted but you can only hint
that's bad it's bad intellectually and i
think it's bad morally it means that you
become
your contract is no longer with your
readers
and my what i try and do and the reason
i write in long hand and write in
isolation
is to say the only the only person i
have a deal with is the person who might
read this and i'll give them my best i
don't care what the editor thinks the
advertising department thinks
friends and colleagues think you try and
live
as if none of those people counted
what's the best account i can give the
customers of this most of washington
punditry is nothing of the kind it's
it's
private letters written to other pundits
and appearing in public
space
have you done as well
in this business as you expected to
better than i expected to
better than i expected to not as well as
i
um would have
um
once or tried to be believed by my
teachers who were always telling me
come on hitchens you could you shouldn't
be sitting there muldering you should be
daniel defeo or something so they held
me to impossible standards but
better than i am better than expected
yeah can you make a difference because
because there isn't in the in this
country
decent living yes yeah america is very
generous to people who who write on the
whole
if they keep at it i mean there are
there are rewards for it the people who
were willing to print it and pay you
do do are there people who genuinely
dislike you that you come in contact
with they're ought to be by now i mean
i've certainly done my best if i if i
didn't have enemies probably people i
don't know about as well as those i do i
would have obviously failed
i would have would have meant i hadn't
been drawing blood when i had certainly
meant to how do you know when you
you've gotten to people well sometimes
they will come up to you and speak you
ever had a confrontation
some confrontation you had on a
television show one time where whales
were that means
but
got a little physical
i thought it was going to get physical
as much yes i thought it was the most i
thought it was just a such a disgrace
that such a man could be an attorney
general in a country that has a justice
department that
i had to tell him everything i thought
about him and and he wasn't
which is not my fault used to hearing
that kind of thing
look um
i mean there's a bit of a digression but
the scandal that he helped covered up
the iran-conscious scandal was
was also covered up of course and lied
about by bethel reagan and george bush
reagan did say one truthful thing about
it
he said if it wasn't for that rag in
beirut
we'd never have had all this trouble
and i thought that was true it wasn't
for a newspaper in beirut the iran
contra scandal never would have come
tonight and yet how many journalists
would you say that are in washington
well-paid
well-informed well-connected
thousands of them who never broke the
story
who a lot of them didn't believe it even
when it came out that's a pretty
tremendous indictment
what do you think of um and so i try as
far as i can not to get too accustomed
to
you know the the culture of journalism
because i think
it's
likely to be the outsiders that will do
the best work but you said you were
social
i like to go to uh gatherings and i like
to
meet the people firsthand i always liked
that's why i used to go to the oxford
union when i was at university and
debate against
actual politicians and try and have
dinner with them afterwards because
you very swiftly found out it's very
good for your education they didn't
really know very much more than you did
and they weren't that much smarter it
was a good way of demystifying politics
looking at something called how
neo-conservatives perish
do you remember this one sure by the way
did you select all these were this your
choice well i mean i selected i threw
out the ones that i didn't think could
possibly be reprinted because they
either were no good
which was true in awful number of cases
or they'd gone out of time they were
written just for that week or that day
and wouldn't survive and so the ones
that could bear reprinting i made a pile
then i gave that to an editor and said
you decide which ones you think
would make the cut so i left that to
them how many books do you have to sell
them to be successful with this i have
no idea i've never got
it's a figure larger than any book
i've ever written as ever sold
but most of my books don't make back the
money
the small sum of money that i'm paid to
write them
i don't know why i don't have any knack
there at all
it's a wonder in fact i mean there are
very very few publishers these days who
will take a risk on a book that won't
make money
um and i'm probably exhausting the
patience of um
this is verso publishing yeah well
that's the publishing arm of new left
books it's a very fine publishing firm
by the way it's extremely it's published
some wonderful books but
it it has to take permanent risks on
opposition writing and unknown writers
i mean they probably would never let me
down but increasingly the mainstream
publishing industry i think
wants an assurance upfront that
everything's commercial and that you've
got a tie-in of some sort of
civilizational maybe a movie deal and
i'm i'm no
you know good at that i wish i was
in this piece in harpers of 1990 how
neo-conservatives perish
you talk about uh
key words and phrases uttered with the
proper sneer
um disinformation dupe
ripe fruit choke point fellow traveler
uh fifth columnist chamberlain's
umbrella captive nation peace through
strength moral equivalence
yeah don't you remember what it was like
don't you remember what sort of hooligan
atmosphere there was in american
intellectual life for a long time
because of the cold war that anyone who
had any doubts that this war was worth
fighting and um worth the risk of a
nuclear exchange was accused of being a
dupe or a secret sympathizer or um
or a fan of neville chamberlain's
umbrella or all these other things it
was people were constantly being crushed
and coerced and derided and sort of
driven out of the argument and i i
wanted to put that down before people
forget it
all these people were ostensibly
there meaning a conference of
conservatives neoconservatives to take
personal credit for the final collapse
of communism why then do they look and
sound so lost and deflated like a herd
of ants in search of a climate no it's a
herd of antis in search of a climate
excuse me my eyes are back well no maybe
there's a misprint
well i was i was
convinced that partly because they'd
lost their
willingness excuse me not their
willingness they'd lost their ability to
be able to bully and blackmail the
opposition and accuse it of treachery
and sympathy for the other side
that uh that was one of the reasons
that the right wing is nostalgic for the
cold war that it's lost its free pass as
being
the patriots where everyone else is
disloyal it's not the whole thing i mean
they've also lost a lot of their
subsidies which i think makes them
squeal even louder these people used to
have
very fat foundations supporting any
project if there's however mediocre or
crackpotted now they don't have that
anymore
and we're also beginning to count the
cost of cold war to the united states
which is um
which is pretty enormous to say nothing
of the damage that it did in other
countries around the world did you go to
that conference yeah sure i sat through
every minute of it how they treat you
they know you're there to
probably write something they would
they wouldn't let me they had a queue of
people for the microphones to ask
questions and
join the line it was noticed even by
some conservative uh
people that are present who actually had
the decency to protest about it but as
soon as it came to my turn to
get to the microphone no one pod horizon
who was the chairman of the thing cut
off the discussion at that point i mean
it was
so blatant as to be um laughable but i
was flattered by it
who's your favorite conservative writer
in the united states william sapphire a
very great admirer of his
i think he's a i think he's a wonderful
writer i think he's a very humorous
writer i think he's quite a brave writer
too
he tries to remember that even though
you know his own
when his own team are in power that you
that doesn't mean you're obliged to stop
criticizing who's your favorite liberal
writer
do you think liberals make very good
writers
um i think liberals are always trying to
have it both ways they both want to be
um they want to share in the idea that
capitalism is basically the best
humanity can do
um but they want to be able to be
compassionate about it i mean i think
that leads to a rather stickly kind of
writing that's what you get from anthony
lewis for example i find it very hard
to read and i think i think it is harder
to read than it is to write
i think of the radical writers though
there are some outstanding cases this
well i mentioned gaufey down already who
i think is one of the best writers of
this or any other time
and who is the person i i've most i
guess tried to model myself on in that
he's so much of a polymath and he has
such a range and his
tries to synthesize literature and
politics very brilliantly
so i openly confess to
to a sort of um
wrong to say penis entry for governor
wouldn't it but you know what i mean
and then there's alexander coburn my
colleague of the nation is extreme
master writer of polenic and
and um
there's
currently operating in print well you
see the problem is that i mean if i was
to mention many other names there would
be names that never see never see the
mass
media because
in effect the the left doesn't exist as
a regular contributor to the ongoing
national discussion on tv and
radio and the print
the nation june 1991 what the hell did
general norman schwarzkopf think he was
doing when he accepted while he was
still a senior serving officer a
knighthood from queen elizabeth ii
yes
question i could never get him or anyone
at the pentagon to answer the
constitution of the united states which
i
am
well consecrated to admiring um because
i come from a country that doesn't have
a constitution and so i think i
appreciate it maybe more than
people take it for granted very clearly
says that um american
serving officials shall not take
decorations or titles of honor from any
foreign
monarch or head of state and there was
schwarzkopf being knighted by
queen elizabeth i thought what is this
we're supposed to have a republic here
and a republic of laws at that and i
can't stand it when people think that
the highest honor
that can
come to them is to be allowed to sprawl
at the feet of the house of windsor
which is uh
dysfunctional royal family that is now
pretty much discredited even in england
february 1991 the nation again bush and
churchillian delusions
according to the 11 february issue of
the new republic the scene that follows
occurred one day after the proud
inauguration of operation desert storm
it starts off that jack kemp the
secretary of housing and urban
development brought a copy of winston
and clementine
a book about the church hills to the
cabinet meeting on on january the 17th
intending to give it to president bush
and you go on to say there's more
what was your point that bush um
throughout that whole war
uh and especially in the run-up to it
constantly compared himself to churchill
and compared the the confrontation that
he was faced with
to the one churchill had had to endure
in 1939 borrowed from the speeches used
phrases like the defining hour and so on
which are
knockoffs of churchill speeches in 1939
1940 wanted the comparison to be made in
the senate debate
for and against the war the churchill
munich analogy was used more often even
than vietnam
uh as a test of you know which side you
were on and i again wondered why it is
the united states people
are such pushovers for this this english
mythology and i also said there was no
way that however it was sliced that bush
could come off as churchill after all as
we now know
um the the war with and as a lot of us
guessed at the time the war with saddam
hussein was a quarrel that had broken
out between two business partners bush
and hussein who were fighting over the
spoils they wanted to involve everyone
else in it
and they wanted for it to sound noble
and they fooled a lot of people for some
of the time
but as as you know the disillusionment
with that war and the rhetoric with
which it was fought is now pretty near
total
you spent some time in jail
didn't you spend some time in jail in
prague in jail in prague yes i did i
thought
for me i thought this
this was to be the consequence of my i
was saying
um
what i said about the great tragic war
in the desert yeah i did i got locked up
in czechoslovakia in
1988 i think it was i went with a
delegation of people there to meet the
czech opposition
and we got caught um
trying to hold a seminar and we were
locked up and then deported was that why
and i wrote a piece then saying that i
thought it was obvious that um
that the czech
and polish and these german and
bulgarian regimes
the russian empire needs to know it was
going to collapse because
it was
it seemed to me absolutely clear that
the regime had no further support was
simply living on police tactics
was it like being in jail
in my case it was exhilarating because
of the people i was locked up with who
were wonderful um
a very nice selection of various western
human rights activists and some
incredibly brave
czechs who
of course were taking much more risk
than we were because we knew probably we
were going to get taken to the airport
and thrown out
and they might have to stay for rather
longer but what impressed me about them
was that many of them had not even been
born at the time of the soviet invasion
in 1968
so that
um they had no memory as it were of the
pre-existing regime they've been brought
up under the
russian dispensation and they they'd
seen through it completely and were
prepared to take risks to defy it
i thought well that that spells the end
for them
when you're done i think i was right
about that actually when you're deciding
um where to go and and what to write
what kind of i mean is there travel
money for you to go anywhere will the
nation send you anywhere
no not usually the best way to do it is
to just do it and then see if you can't
sell the articles when you come back
that's what i had to do with bosnia for
example i thought i really must go and
see what's happening in sorry i can't
not go
when did you go last summer
go there um in sarajevo
two and a half to three days and nights
which is not long but it's plenty i can
tell you unless you are
as some good reporters are able to put
up with a lot by way of being sort of
bombarded and shot at and
kept permanently scared and i felt that
i've got the point about being
permanently scared after a few days and
it's also quite a small city and i was
able to see
a lot of it in the remainder of the
country of bosnia and
surrounding bits of
of croatia and slovenia
rather longer
but not not at such high risk and
i thought really i have to go the
problem was i had no particular
credential to represent
anybody but i just thought it was a sort
of responsibility to go and see what it
looked like and i've been very i think
i've bored you with this in the past
i've become very
obsessed with it since and then i just
wrote a number of pieces and
sort of made back the money of the
ticket that way do you travel as a
british citizen or an american citizen
responsible
intended well rather i mean what i'd
rather say is and the reason i kept the
british passport is european passport
because
as of 1992 there is now a euro passport
that makes you
free to travel
within the boundaries of 12 member
countries and i've always liked the idea
of european unity and so i held out for
a euro passport so i travel as a
european
will you ever change your citizenship
well i
you you asked me if i said to you i'm an
american you'd say but that's not true
you're really an englishman and
i think that i think i would always
probably sound and seem to be english so
it would seem odd to me say i was an
american in england
also i was an american here so i have a
green card
resident alien as they say
and um
and uh european passport and i sort of
think that's
a form of being an internationalist
going back to work on two pretentious
going back to where we started on uh
your your piece uh
section of this book called rogue's
gallery by the way there are a lot of
things we have not talked about in this
book uh and they have to do with your
opinion of
things other than american yes um how
did you mix that i mean is this book
being sold in both countries sure is it
being sold is being translated in the
other any other language we haven't had
any offers that i know about but usually
every book gets translated into japanese
these days they're tremendously
omnivorous in getting and getting to
read everything and i i'd love to see
myself in japanese
uh how did you decide this this
particular uh item is out of a
thing called descent fall of 1990.
what's dissent dissent is the magazine
that's associated with the late irving
howe who you may have read about i say
the late because he died i think the
month before last we're now in what
first of september today
irving howe was a great old self-made
writer
scholar essayist socialist critic
best known for a book called world of
our fathers which is a wonderful account
of the origins of
jewish life in new york from the first
immigration to the lower east side and
then the burgeoning out to become
i guess the most successful of america's
minorities
um and he discovered um the writing in
yiddish of isaac singer isaac bauschev
singer who later won the nobel prize who
was scribbling away unknown in in
yiddish only
kind of small magazines in new york and
he discovered him and had him translated
and made him world famous and he also
founded a magazine called descent which
is published four times a year i believe
and i write for occasionally
this is a piece called nixon uh maestro
of resentment
and you lead off this thing by by saying
but as i read this the latest of his
awful books
uh
over the years has richard nixon been
someone that you've uh found easy to
write about
yeah and also difficult because as i say
in that piece there's always the
temptation to feel sorry for him
um i mean i fight it down this
temptation i try not to give in to any
promptings of compassion or or pity let
me read this there is something sad and
lonely and desperate and artificial
about the guy
and and it does occasionally give you a
pang and
that piece is about
about trying to fight off the pack well
you wrote this this
sentence you said the interesting bits
of nixon's private existence the foul
mouth
the jew hating the paranoia yeah all lie
under a ban of denial and are bled out
of the narrative yes
i mean the nixon of the tapes where he
makes as you know
terrible remarks about how the jews are
behind his persecution the jews are
behind the anti-war movement the jews
are behind the arts life in america it
tells his children to stay away from the
jews and even uses
foul words like kayak yet and so on
those are all the tapes and you can
actually go and hear them as well as
read them if you if you care to or you
can stand it
in his book he just it's not that he
says look i was overwrought at the time
and i meant you know i shouldn't have
generalized
or something he just doesn't discuss it
at all it's different guy writing
than the person who's on the tapes this
is a
it's
would be dignifying that to call it
schizophrenia i think it's simply
dishonest
you started all this by saying it's good
for you to get up in the morning angry
if you're a writer what are you angry
about now oh by the way that reminds me
of someone i criminally left out when
you asked i thought was that was the
great uh radical writer at the moment i
left out uh professor noam chomsky who i
mean i think is
one of the most extraordinary moral
human beings of our time and who's
produced a shelf
of books and critiques and findings and
carefully calibrated
work that holds up a mirror to american
policy and society that it should look
in more often the reason i'm reminded of
it is that um
there's a wonderful story about norm who
went to the dentist one day it's true
and the dentist said you're grinding
your teeth and
he said no i'm not as far as i know and
he said a lot of my patients say that
you're probably grinding them when
you're asleep and his wife sort of
monitored around the clock and he wasn't
doing it
went asleep and they monitored him more
closely and they found he was only
grinding his teeth
in the morning when he was reading the
new york times
and i
i
think hey that's a great story about
chomsky all of whose stuff anyone
watching this should rush out and buy
and is an example to us all
but also because i have the same
experience reading the mainstream take
on daily
life every day and the way that the
editorials refer to we as if we were all
one big family and it was all up to us
and one thing society is not is a family
not even a dysfunctional one
and the way it's always assumed that the
consensus comes first and
the bright little ways in which they
sort of package the news and make it
digestible for us
always starts me off feeling thoroughly
pissed off every day what how about an
individual that makes you the angriest
these days
janet reno is particularly annoying me
at the moment i think
again not not so not just because i
don't think she's anything like as good
as people say but because people keep
saying how great she is and you ask them
why is that and then they don't they
can't really tell you and i'm completely
furious with her for burying the iraq
gate scandal for taking the bush quail
line that there was no nothing sinister
about the bank in atlanta that was
arming saddam
for uh for for the later war between
business partners that we all had to go
through how much longer are you going to
do this
until i grew up
in this country if they'll help me
this is what the cover of this
book looks like it's a compendium of
articles
in various publications including
harpers in the nation and others
christopher hitchens thank you for
joining us thank you
[Music]
join us next week for book notes when
our guest will be william f buckley jr
founder and editor-at-large of the
national review
he'll be here to discuss his recent book
titled
happy days we're here again reflections
of a libertarian journalist
that's book notes next sunday night at 8
and 11 p.m eastern time on c-span
coming next a look at television
coverage of the british house of commons
[Music]
for a transcript of this edition of book
notes please send five dollars to c-span
transcripts in care of tape writer
incorporated post office box 885 in
lincolnshire illinois the zip code is
60069
it's time now